these environmental activists are
storming the brown coal power plant
cultivates a bumper or black pump and
allows its region in eastern Germany
they say the cold burned at the plant
pollutes the air and contributes to
climate change
other activists have occupied the
railway tracks leading to the plant
stopping deliveries of cold what is
forced believes terrible how attitudes
towards coal have developed in recent
years on the one hand we're expanding
renewable energy and phasing out nuclear
power but we're still supporting coal
power that's nuts beside the swedish
company Vattenfall owns the schwartz a
pumper plant and it loses money on it
each year now a company in the Czech
Republic wants to take over the brown
coal operations in eastern Germany the
demonstrators are opposed to that for a
whole weekend they plan to blockade the
plant and try to stop the burning of
coal for at least a few hours a student
who asks us not to use his name is
planning the occupation of the
earthmovers at the opencast mine the
sensya is our end goal is to show the
new investor the new buyer that if he
buys this area he's also buying our
protest which will continue over the
next year's autumn Nix niets oddity they
say they're practicing civil
disobedience which includes knowingly
breaking the law they walk for hours
through the forest toward the strip mine
for them saving the planet is worth any
effort helps assist easy we're here
today mainly because of climate change
also the fact that burning coal releases
a lot of radioactivity into the air in
addition to the carbon dioxide that's
released compared to other energy
sources is just not sustainable he's met
talk why after two hours they've reached
the strip mine now they have to move
fast before the police or the security
guards catch them by entering these
grounds they're risking being charged
with trespassing or even breach of the
public peace if they end up damaging
something
if the earth movers are stopped for good
the region stands to lose some 8,000
jobs but if brown coal mining continues
numerous towns will have to be bulldozed
Matias kasbah is among those who would
lose their homes
though the electrician makes a living
doing technical service on wind farms he
opposes closing the brown coal mines he
says the end of mining would cost many
of his friends and neighbors and almost
the whole town their jobs depaul kullu
come on we can't abandon brown coal
mining right now the energy transition
is important but it's a process that
will take decades we can't just shut
down the coal plants that would throw us
back to the Stone Age that's something
all these people need to understand
they're bringing life here to a
standstill with their protests possible
to this 300 kilometres away in the Czech
Republic here Cole is the most important
energy source next to nuclear power
there's enough brown coal here to last
at least 20 years Prague is the home of
the company eph which wants to buy the
brown coal and allows its region the
company refuses an on-camera interview
citing ongoing business negotiations
journalist Petra Lucas says that the man
behind the deal is one of the country's
most colorful entrepreneurs the
millionaire Danielle krichinsky he's a
kind of oligarchs who buys a power
plants across Europe by taking over
Germany's brown coal industry he's
betting against quick implementation of
renewable sources what I think is that
he counts on the fact that call will be
still needed that the trans transition
to renewable energy in Germany will be
slower in several years you want to shut
down your nuclear power plants and you
will have to it's not sure whether you
have enough enough renewable the
demonstrators think it's unlikely that
Germany's energy transition will fail
and brown coal will enjoy a revival but
to make sure that doesn't happen they're
willing to risk arrest and penalties
you